so this morning the prime minister  chaired a meeting of the national  security council  attendees at that meeting took full  account of the national cyber security  center's advice  together with the implications for uk  industry and why a g  wider geo strategic considerations the  government agrees with the national  cyber security center advice  the best way to secure our networks  is for operators to stop using new  affected hawaii  equipment to build the uk's future 5g  networks so to be clear from the end of  this year  telecoms operators must not buy any 5g  equipment from huawei  and once the telecom security bill is  passed it will be  illegal for them to do so